so we have f of x being equal to the
absolute value of x plus two and we will
and we want to evaluate the definite
integral from negative four to zero of f
of x dx and like always pause this video
and see if you could work through this
now when you first do this you might
stumble around a little bit because how
do you take the anti-derivative of an
absolute value function and the key here
is to one way to approach it is to
rewrite f of x without the absolute
value and we can do that by rewriting it
as a piecewise function
and the way i'm going to do it i'm going
to think about intervals where what we
what we where where whatever we take
inside the absolute value is going to be
positive and other intervals where
everything that we take inside the
absolute value is going to be negative
and the the point at which we change is
where
x plus 2 is equal to 0 or x is equal to
negative 2. so let's just think about
the intervals x is less than negative 2
and x is greater than or equal to
negative 2. and this could have been
less than or equal in which case this
would have been greater than either way
it would have been equal to this
absolute value this is a continuous
function here
and so when well let's do the easier
case when x is greater than or equal to
negative 2 then x plus 2 is going to be
positive or it's going to be it's going
to be greater than or equal to 0 and so
the absolute value of it is just going
to be the x plus 2. so it's going to be
x plus 2 when x is greater than or equal
to negative 2 and what about when x is
less than negative 2 well when x is less
than negative 2 x plus 2 is going to be
negative and then if you take the
absolute value of a negative number
you're going to take the opposite of it
so this is going to be negative
x plus 2.
and to really help grok this because
frankly this is the hardest part of what
we're doing and really this is more
algebra than calculus let me draw the
absolute value function to make this
clear so that is my
x-axis
that is my
y-axis and let's say we're here at
negative two
and so when
we are less than negative 2
when x is less than negative 2 my graph
is going to look like this
it is going to
it is going to look
look something let's see what is it's
going to look like that
and when we are greater than negative 2
we do that in a different color
when we are greater than negative 2 it's
going to look like this
it's going to look like that
and so notice
this is in blue we have this is the
graph x plus 2. we can say this is a
graph of y equals x plus 2. and what we
have in magenta right over here this is
the graph of negative x minus 2 it has a
negative slope and we intercept the y
axis at negative 2. so it makes sense
there's multiple ways that you could
reason through this
now once we break it up then we can
break up the integral we could say that
what we wrote here this is equal to the
integral from negative 4 to 2 sorry
negative 4 to negative 2
of f of x which is which is in that case
it's going to be
negative x
minus 2. i just distributed the negative
sign there
d x
and then plus
plus
the definite integral going from
negative 2
to 0
of
x plus 2
dx and just to make sure we know what
we're doing here this if this is
negative 4 right over here this is 0.
that first integral is going to give us
is going to give us this area
right over here what's the area under
the curve negative x minus 2
under that curve or under that line and
above the x axis
and the second integral is going to give
us this area
right over here between x plus 2 and
and the x-axis going from negative 2 to
0.
and so let's evaluate each of these and
you might even be able to just evaluate
these with a little bit of triangle
areas but let's just do this
analytically or algebraically
and so what's the anti-derivative of
negative x well that's negative x
squared over 2 and then we have the
minus the negative 2 or so the
anti-derivative is negative 2x we're
going to evaluate that
at
at negative
at
negative 2
and negative 4.
and so that part is going to be what
negative 2
squared so it's the negative of negative
2 squared so it's negative 4 over 2
minus 2 times negative 2. so plus 4
so that's it evaluated at negative 2
and then minus
if we evaluated it at negative 4
so minus
so we're going to have minus negative 4
squared is 16 over 2
minus 2 times negative 4. so that is
plus
plus 8.
so what is that what is that going to
give us
so this is
this is negative two
this right over here is negative
eight
so the second term right over here is
just going to be equal to zero did i do
that right yeah the 16 over two it's
negative and it's positive okay so this
is just going to be 0
and this is negative 2 plus 4
which is going to be equal to 2.
so what we have here in magenta is equal
to 2 and what we have here in blue
well let's see this is the
antiderivative of
x squared over 2 plus 2x
we're going to evaluate it at 0 and
negative 2. you evaluate this thing at 0
it's just going to be 0 and from that
you're going to subtract negative 2
squared over 2 that is
positive 4 over 2 which is positive 2
and then plus 2 times negative 2. so
minus
minus 4
and so this is going to be
this is going to be the negative of
negative 2 or positive 2. so it's 2 plus
2 and that makes sense that what we have
in magenta here is 2 and what we have
over here is two there's a symmetry here
there is a symmetry here and so you add
them all together
and you get our integral is going to be
equal to four and once again just as a
reality check you could say look the
height here is 2 the width the base here
is 2 2 times 2 times 1 half is indeed
equal to 2 same thing over here so
that's the more geometric argument for
why that area is 2 that area is 2 add
them together you get positive 4.